cette quatrième partie du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale ce
sont des réformes et des moyens majeurs
pour avancer vers un modèle social plus
juste et plus protecteur
ce texte ce sont 21 milliards d'euros en
plus entre 2021 et 2023 pour financer le
système de santé ce sont des mesures
nouvelles et concrètes pour la
prévention des consultations aux âges
clés de la vie un accès simple et
gratuit pour les dépistage ou pour la
contraception d'urgence ce sont des
avancées pour améliorer l'accès aux
soins par de nouvelles compétences
confiées aux infirmiers et aux
pharmaciens et de nouveaux mécanismes
pour une meilleure présence médicale à
travers le territoire je sais que
l'accès aux soins est une préoccupation
largement partagée sur tous les bancs de
cette hémicycle nous devons aller plus
loin et c'est un objectif central des
négociations qui s'ouvrent entre
l'assurance maladie et les syndicats de
médecins
ce sont des services supplémentaires
pour les personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie avec un renforcement des
heures d'accompagnement à domicile et
des moyens supplémentaires pour les
EHPAD ce sont des mesures nouvelles de
soutien à la garde d'enfants notamment
pour les familles monoparentales ce sont
des avancées concrètes pour les Français
et pour les professionnels
ce sont
ce sont des avancées attendues nous
devons collectivement permettre qu'elle
soit votée
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la quatrième partie et l'ensemble du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023
mesdames et messieurs les députés montez
à cette tribune pour engager la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement n'est
jamais un acte banal mais nous avons un
devoir de cohérence un devoir de
résultats les Français ont besoin de
leur sécurité sociale ce projet de loi
propose des réformes décisives et des
moyens majeurs alors en responsabilité
nous devons avancer je vous remercie je
vous remercie madame la Première
ministre Trump donc l'Assemblée
nationale prend acte de l'engagement
d'un responsabilité du gouvernement
conformément aux disposition de
l'articles 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution le texte sur lequel la
première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
insérée en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa premier du
règlement le débat sur ce texte est
immédiatement suspendu ce texte sera
considéré comme adopté sauf si une
motion de censure déposée avant demain
23h45 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 proche de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
notion de censure serait déposée la
Conférence des Présidents sera convoquée
lundi 28 novembre à 15h30 pour fixer la
date et les modalités de sa discussion
en conséquence sous réserves des
dispositions et des décisions prises par
la Conférence des Présidents la
prochaine séance aura lieu le lundi 28
novembre à 16h et nous commencerons par
une proposition de résolution en soutien
au mouvement pour la liberté du peuple
iranien je vous remercie la séance
élevée